SPEAKER: Thanks to
machine learning,
we can extract knowledge from
medical records, call center
conversations, medical voice
soundbites, medical forms,
regulatory filings, research
reports, insurance claims,
pharmaceutical
documentation, and more.
This ultimately helps
doctors and care teams
get holistic views of
their patients quickly,
or health plans to
see population trends
for their members, or
pharma to draw insights
from drug development research.
This is possible thanks to a
field known as natural language
processing, which is concerned
with programming computers
to process and analyze large
bodies of human communication
that can live in many
different formats,
such as written texts,
spoken utterances, or even
official documentation.
And so in this episode, we
will share how organizations
can use one of Google's
natural language services
to specifically help
process structured
and unstructured
health care language
data using NLP, which stands
for Natural Language Processing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The Healthcare
Natural Language API
contains four key features that
help you find, assess, and link
knowledge in your data
in the following ways.
For one, it has
the ability to text
to medical concepts,
which is referred
to as knowledge extraction.
It also identifies and connects
related medical attributes,
which is known as
relation extraction.
It can also assess
surrounding factors
that could be
clinically relevant,
known as context assessment, and
standardizes medical concepts
so they can be analyzed
across systems,
known as knowledge linking.
Another way of
thinking about NLP
is that it can extract
critical clinical information,
like medications,
medical conditions,
as well as understand
contexts, like negation,
such as, this patient
does not have diabetes.
It also understands temporality,
such as, this patient will
start chemotherapy tomorrow,
and even infer there
are relationships
between things,
such as side effects
or medication dosage.
And what's most
notable is we have
a long list of ontologies
the natural language
models are trained with.
Two notable ones
are the ICD, which
is used to code and classify
morbidity data from inpatient
and outpatient records,
physician offices, and most
National Center for
Health Statistics surveys.
There's also SNOMED
clinical terms,
which provides core terminology
of electronic health records.
The models also include
US official codes
for insurance
procedures and RxNorm,
which contains a list of
all medications available.
Technical practitioners
can leverage healthcare NLP
to build apps for
their own organization
or for their entire industry,
such as enabling precise search
and discoverability across
patient populations,
enable exchange of digital
health care information
and avoid processing delays,
establish and maintain
regulatory compliance,
or automate
administrative workflows, such
as identifying and eliminating
errors that require
corrective activities.
Anyone who has science-based
texts around research
or clinical data can get value
from our Healthcare NLP API.
Here are a few sectors that
can benefit to name a few.
In telehealth, you now
have off-the-shelf support
for exchanging medical knowledge
captured in written form
and can extract structured
knowledge from texts
and make it available
for digital services,
such as chat bots, call centers,
clinical decision support
systems.
This also frees up time
by triaging patient calls
and resolving cases that do
not require the intervention
of a clinical professional.
Pharmaceutical
researchers are also
enabled via a standard
patient discovery
interface for population
health and R&D applications,
since papers and clinical
trial documentation
can be surfaced to
match patients or find
novel treatments.
Those managing
clinical trials can
both increase their
number of participants,
as well as process the
high volume of feedback
and decrease time to
government approval.
Users who manage
billing, especially
in insurance companies, can
have even better integration
with claims payment or
automate billing and coding
for insurance.
You can enable
the Healthcare NLP
from your Google Cloud Projects
UI or via the command line.
If you do not have
a project, there's
a link in the description along
with other helpful resources.
And once you have
setup permissions
you can begin using its
context-aware models
to extract medical
entities, relations,
and contextual attributes.
Each text entity is extracted
into a medical dictionary
entry.
To extract medical,
texts make a POST request
and specify the following
information in the request.
First, the name of
the parent service,
including the project
ID and location.
Also, the target text.
The maximum size is
10,000 Unicode characters
at this time.
Let's quickly show you how
you can leverage the Natural
Language Healthcare API.
We built a demo application
with a JavaScript frontend
to visually understand the
output of the Healthcare NLP
API.
Let's test out the
sample medical record
for a hospital patient.
We send over the
sample medical tests
to the API on the backend, and
we render the JSON response
in this web app.
In the first panel
down here, we can
see the various
entities extracted
and their corresponding
medical code.
Next, we can see their diagnoses
with their corresponding
confidence scores.
Now looking at the relationships
between the entities,
we can actually group
together important attributes.
For example, take
a look at how long
and how much of
these medications
are taken or were prescribed.
There are so many possibilities
when using Healthcare NLP,
and especially when you pair
it with Google services,
such as Dialogflow AI
for a chatbot interface.
You can even build custom models
to build low-code apps using
AutoML Entity Extraction
for Healthcare,
so that users can simply
upload documents and then
perform manual annotations to
train and build a model on what
they would like to extract.
This can then be integrated
into larger data pipelines.
You can also use Document AI
to process faxed documents
or enable enterprise
search for life science
organizations using the
Google Knowledge Graph.
To learn more about the
Healthcare Natural Language
API, you can visit
cloud.google.com
/healthercare/do
cs/concepts/nlp.
And community, if you
found this episode helpful,
please subscribe to the
channel to get notifications
of more health care episodes.
Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]